Did that one TVA agent's voice sound creepily
familiar on the second season premiere of
"Loki"? If it did, you're probably a "Call
of Duty" fan. Here's how you may know him.
Minor spoilers for Loki Season 2 Episode 1 ahead!
Most everyone knows that Marvel's Disney+
original series "Loki" stars Tom Hiddleston
as the title's trickster god of Norse
mythology, complete with shiny hair and
an irrepressible need to be the snarkiest
person in the room. Plenty of members of
the supporting cast are quite well known as
well, such as Owen Wilson and Gugu Mbatha-Raw,
or the most recent addition to the
ensemble, Oscar winner Ke Huy Quan.
But not everyone in the cast is an award winner or
a top-billed star, at least not yet. For example:
Neil Ellice, a Scottish actor whose
voice might be more famous than his face.
On "Loki," Ellice portrays Hunter D-90,
the stick-in-the-mud Minuteman who prunes
Wilson's Mobius on the orders of Mbatha-Raw's
Ravonna Renslayer. He changes his tune after he
realizes that every single member of the
Time Variance Authority is a kidnapped,
memory-wiped, and brainwashed variant, stolen from
somewhere on the timeline. Apparently, it's a lot
harder to commit genocide when you qualify as a
potential candidate for the murder spree yourself.
Like many supporting cast members, Ellice
returns for "Loki" Season 2 and has a
delightfully awkward conversation
with Mobius in which he almost,
but not quite, apologizes for
the whole "killing him" thing.
"Mobius, I was just doing my job."
"You mean, pruning me? Yeah,
well. I guess you were just following orders."
Ellice seems to find great success in his
portrayals of soldiers who know how to follow
orders. Obviously, there's Hunter D-90,
but there's also Captain John MacTavish,
better known by his code name, Soap, from the
"Call of Duty" video game franchise. Ellice voices
the character in multiple "Modern Warfare"
entries and numerous spinoff games. Outside
of these projects, however, which he proudly
features at the top of his social media pages,
his résumé is relatively sparse, with his only
other roles unnamed background characters.
Before entering the professional screen and
voice acting business, Ellice performed on
stage. His education prepared him for live
theater; he trained at the National Youth
Theatre of Great Britain and the Royal Academy
of Dramatic Art's Shakespeare Summer School. Yes,
that means that our muscle-bound Minuteman is
a former theater kid. He's also something of an
outdoorsman, based on his love of hiking and the
countryside. On top of all that, he appears to
be a dedicated gym bro. This is starting to sound
dangerously like a dating profile bio, isn't it?
In November 2022, Ellice sat down with Dan Allen
Gaming for an interview about "Call of Duty:
Modern Warfare II" in support of the charities
Game on Cancer and Call of Duty Endowment.
While he's proud of his Scottish heritage -- his
Instagram bio sports the Scottish Gaelic phrase
for "Scotland forever" -- it appears that his
natural Scottish accent wasn't quite Scottish
enough for Soap, so he ramped it up to make the
character's Glasgow origins more believable.
"Like any accent from any country, some
accents are going to be thicker than others."
Ellice's Scottish accent is entirely absent
on "Loki," though. The best description of
Hunter D-90's voice is "angry American monotone."
"Looks like your favorite
Loki betrayed you, Mobius."
Most of the time, he doesn't speak at
all. He just stares in moody silence.
Even getting to the point where he
could half apologize to Mobius must
have exerted every ounce of his willpower.
But hey, that's growth. Maybe he'll get more
time in "Loki" Season 2 to squeeze
out the other half of that apology.
Marvel's "Loki" Season 2 is streaming now,
with new episodes hitting Disney+ every
Thursday through November 9, 2023.